in the infinite game the only competitor
you truly have is yourself how do we
make our products better this year than
they were last year how do we make our
systems better than the this year than
they were last year how do I make our
culture stronger this year than it was
last year how do we hire better this
year than we did last year the goal is
not to beat your competition the goal is
to outlast your competition so this is
raises an interesting question if too
many leaders are playing with the wrong
mindset for the game that they're
actually in to the detriment of their
own businesses then it means that we
have to change our mindset to play by
the for the game that we're actually and
so how do we lead with an infinite
mindset there are five practices that
you have to master in order to lead with
an infinite mindset number one you have
to have a Just Cause
number two you have to have trusting
teams number three you have to have a
worthy rival number four you have to
have a capacity for existential
flexibility and number five you have to
have the courage to lead
[Music]